MURMURING
Hello.
Welcome back to
the white void.
So, again, I am not here
to entertain you today.
I am here because I am feeling really
great right now about myself
and my life and my plans and
I want to talk to you about it.
So the thing about people is that
eventually they grow up,
and at least what I found is that
if you like someone the way that they are,
watching them go through that change
can be a bit weird and uncomfortable,
but at the same time,
it's inevitable.
People do change, and I think if
you try and ignore that fact,
then you're going to find
yourself pretty unhappy,
which I think is basically what
ended up happening to me.
I am not that cute little British boy making
YouTube videos in his bedroom anymore.
I have a mortgage.
I pay taxes.
I have an accountant.
I go to work in an office.
I have a full time job. I mean this,
it's a bit of weird one, but it's still that.
You know, I wouldn't consider myself an
adult really, but I'm clearly not a kid either.
And honestly, now that I can
finally admit that to myself,
I feel like this massive weight
has been lifted off my chest.
Like last year for me I think was
sort of an exercise in me
trying to mimic my younger self because
that's what I thought people wanted to see,
but it's not what I want to do because
that's not the person that I am anymore.
The time has finally come,
I think, for me to make stuff
that really reflects how
I feel I've change,
and I've been trying to make that transition
a bit already sort of in small ways,
but to really push myself,
I've come up with this slightly mad plan
to take me through
the rest of the year,
one that I am both very excited and
more than a little bit nervous about.
You may remember once
upon a time I said I was
working on a screenplay
for a short film,
which, no, I still haven't finished,
but narrative filmmaking is still something
I really want to have a
proper go at.
It's the thing I get most excited about when
I'm working on anything at the moment,
and so what I'm going to do is
instead of making a short film,
I am going to make five of them,
one every two months
for the rest of the year,
starting in April.
To go with those, I also want to make a
behind the scenes video for each of the shorts
and, you know, I want to continue to
make whatever I want to make as well.
Your regular
YouTube content,
what you've come to expect
from me on this channel,
that is not going to stop.
Although, it may be a bit more
mature or more immature.
I haven't really
decided yet,
but basically, you will see something
from me every one or two weeks.
And that is a commitment I have
made publicly, so that's good.
My goal with all of this, ultimately,
is just to connect with you
in the best way that I possibly can
by doing and making the things
that make me happy and
sharing them with you.
You know, I want to
challenge your expectations
of what it is that you
expect from me,
and I mean really what I want
to do is stop talking about it
and show you that I'm serious
about this by just doing it.
But just before I go, I do want to say
thank you so much for sticking with me
through this "I'm Scared"
phase of mine.
It really, really does
mean a lot,
and I guess I just want to ask you to get
excited to see something new from me
because I'm really excited to
make something new for you.
Ugh...
It's going to be great.
My body is ready
for the short films.
Good.
And on that note, goodbye.
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
CHARLIE: I'm very excited to be
filming this video,
and it's over now,
but I don't want to stop.
So, ugh...
Ughh! Doo!
I haven't felt like
this in a while.
This is good.
I should really
stop this.
Okay, goodbye.